Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）共同发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, we are taking a close look at complex trauma and obsessive
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我们将深入探讨复杂性创伤和强迫症。
compulsive disorder. We are chatting with Alexandra, who is somebody who has experienced these things from her childhood, and we piece together what has contributed to what she's experienced in adulthood. I think this is a really interesting topic. I hope it's one that you will relate to. I hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. For those of you who have been in my world for a little while, you might already know that working with people with complex trauma and grief is one of my clinical specialties. This is something that I started in my career in the NHS and have continued into my private practice. But what is complex trauma? What are the symptoms that will commonly crop up, what might contribute to it and how can OCD make sense as a way of
我们将与亚历山德拉（Alexandra）聊天，她从小就经历过这些问题，我们将一起梳理是什么导致了她成年后的经历。我认为这是一个非常有趣的话题。希望你能从中产生共鸣，并觉得它非常有用。你好，欢迎收听《准心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。对于那些关注我一段时间的朋友，你们可能已经知道，与复杂性创伤和悲伤患者合作是我的临床专长之一。这是我职业生涯在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）中开始，并一直延续到私人诊所的工作。但什么是复杂性创伤？常见的症状有哪些？什么因素会导致它？强迫症（OCD）又是如何作为一种
coping and surviving? This is what we are talking about in today's episode as I speak with a real person who has experienced these difficulties. I hope you find it really useful, really interesting and I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi, just want to welcome along our guest for today, Alexandra. Hi, thank you for being here. Hi there, Marianne. It's lovely to be here. Thank you. So we wanted to have a chat today about your experiences growing up and how that's kind of shaped you and what you've reclaimed from that, really. And I know that your book is called Reclaiming Christmas, so I'm sure we'll hear a little bit more about that.
应对和生存方式而产生的呢？这就是我们今天节目要讨论的内容，我将与一位亲身经历过这些困难的人交谈。希望你觉得它非常有用、非常有趣，我期待在节目后与你交流。你好，欢迎我们今天的嘉宾亚历山德拉。你好，谢谢你来到这里。你好，玛丽安。很高兴能来到这里。谢谢。所以我们今天想聊聊你成长过程中的经历，以及这些经历是如何塑造了你，以及你从中找回了什么。我知道你的书名叫《找回圣诞节》（Reclaiming Christmas），所以我相信我们会听到更多关于它的内容。
For anyone that's like, Reclaiming Christmas? Where are we? Like, we're recording this in May, but this is just a book title. It's not a seasonal book, is it? It's a book for anyone that's interested in learning more about trauma. So just before we get going, tell us a little bit about yourself, Alexandra. Yeah, of course. So I started off life in academia. I did a postdoctorate in applied maths and I met my husband who did a postdoctorate in physics. That tended to end quite a lot of conversations when we told people that, because it's a slightly scary combination. But then we moved to London and pursued corporate careers.
对于那些想问“找回圣诞节？我们现在在哪？”的人，我们是在五月录制的，但这只是书名。这不是一本季节性书籍，对吧？这是一本为任何想了解更多关于创伤的人准备的书。那么在开始之前，请向我们介绍一下你自己，亚历山德拉。好的，当然。我最初是在学术界开始我的生活的。我获得了应用数学的博士后学位，我遇到了我的丈夫，他获得了物理学博士后学位。当我们告诉别人这一点时，谈话往往会很快结束，因为这是一个有点吓人的组合。但后来我们搬到了伦敦，追求企业职业生涯。
So I was in the civil service for 12 years and then moved into the charitable sector. But I just wasn't happy and I wasn't well, basically, for that entire time. And so I've been through quite a long journey of getting better and understanding why I had a bit of a myriad of mental health issues. And I've now recently set up my new business, Damsel Not In Distress, to support people to recover after life challenges. And I now live in what is today the very sunny Northwest Highlands of Scotland. Wow, what a journey, what a journey. and I can see why that might have stopped dinner party conversations because of how daunted people must be by the incredible genius of you and your husband
我在公务员系统工作了12年，然后转到了慈善部门。但基本上在那整个期间，我并不快乐，身体也不好。所以我经历了一段很长的康复之旅，去理解为什么我会有各种各样的心理健康问题。我现在刚创办了我的新企业“非落难少女”（Damsel Not In Distress），旨在支持人们在经历生活挑战后恢复。我现在住在苏格兰西北高地，那里今天阳光明媚。哇，多么奇妙的旅程，我明白为什么这会终结晚宴上的谈话了，因为人们一定会被你和你丈夫那令人难以置信的天才所震慑。
combined but North West Scotland sounds beautiful. Yes, well it turned out hill walking has been a massive part of my recovery and I slightly unnerved my husband when we were living in London and it was just after my mother had died about 10 years ago and I said Inerved my husband when we were living in London and it was just after my mother had died about 10 years ago and I said I think we should try to climb all the Munros which are the hills above 3,000 feet the only thing there being there are 282 of them and it's quite a feat to try and climb them all from London because obviously you have a very long journey to even get to the foot of the hill before you can start but we did it all in about seven years and finished just during the pandemic actually and but walking is just a wonderful restorative thing for me so uh we're now here permanently which is
但苏格兰西北部听起来很美。是的，事实证明，爬山是我康复的重要组成部分。当我们住在伦敦时，我母亲去世大约10年后，我曾让我丈夫感到不安，我说我想我们应该尝试攀登所有的芒罗山（Munros，指海拔超过3000英尺的山峰），唯一的问题是总共有282座，从伦敦出发去攀登它们是一项艰巨的任务，因为显然在开始爬山之前，你得先经过漫长的旅程才能到达山脚。但我们在大约七年内完成了所有攀登，实际上是在疫情期间完成的。步行对我来说是一种美妙的恢复方式，所以我们现在永久住在这里，这
beautiful oh amazing that sounds like a pr worthy pitch in itself wanting to climb all of the munros yes it was i at the beginning i had no idea what I was getting myself into, to be honest. But I got incredibly much fitter than I was before and, you know, scrambled up rock faces and did things I'd never imagined I would do. I abseiled, which I seriously never imagined I would do. So, yes, it certainly got me to try out new things and get comfortable with new things. Well, I'm really pleased to hear that you found a wonderful coping strategy. But of course, what would be useful to know is a little bit about what you were trying to cope with and why.
很美。哦，太棒了，听起来想要攀登所有芒罗山本身就是一个值得称赞的壮举。是的，说实话，刚开始时我根本不知道自己卷入了什么。但我变得比以前健康多了，我爬过岩壁，做了我从未想象过自己会做的事情。我玩过速降，我真的从未想过我会做这种事。所以，是的，它确实让我尝试了新事物，并对新事物感到自在。好吧，我很高兴听到你找到了一个很棒的应对策略。但当然，了解你试图应对的是什么以及原因会很有用。
And I'm aware this is not a therapy session. And so I always want you to feel protected and safe in what we're talking about but in terms of our listeners you know they are often psychology students or psychology graduates pursuing professional psychology qualifications and so it would be a really nice opportunity for myself and for our listeners and watchers to kind of get a little bit of an understanding about what complex trauma is, what kind of things might create it. Would that be okay, Alexandra? Of course, and that is part of my mission in life now. So I'm very comfortable to share about it. So the crux of my issues, I now understand, has unfortunately been that I suffered emotional abuse from my father. And that, I believe, started before I was aware, because my first memory of him is being wary of him when I was about four.
我知道这不是心理咨询，所以我总是希望你在谈话中感到被保护和安全。但对于我们的听众来说，他们通常是心理学专业的学生或毕业生，正在追求专业心理学资格，所以这对我和听众来说是一个很好的机会，可以了解什么是复杂性创伤，以及什么样的事情可能会导致它。这样可以吗，亚历山德拉？当然，这也是我现在人生使命的一部分。所以我很乐意分享。我问题的核心，我现在明白，不幸的是我遭受了父亲的情感虐待。我相信这在我意识到之前就开始了，因为我对他的第一记忆是四岁时对他保持警惕。
But I did not realise what the issue was, because it's a bit like, you know, just being that frog in ever increasing hot water, you just don't know what you don't know. And you certainly don't know what normal looks like, or what good looks like, you just know what your environment is. And there's no doubt that my father loved me. But he was a very complicated character. And the best analogy I've come up with is that he was like Jekyll and Hyde, the Robert Louis Stevenson novel, where he could be really loving and caring one minute and then suddenly become really angry and difficult the next. And for a young child, I think not knowing what version of your caregiver is going to pitch up is It's really, really unnerving. But so that's that that is the crux of the story. But if you roll back 20 years, I didn't know any of this. I was a young adult. I already had a few mental health issues. So I had a spider phobia from pretty much as long as I can
但我并没有意识到问题所在，因为这就像温水煮青蛙，你不知道自己不知道什么。你肯定不知道什么是正常的，或者什么是好的，你只知道你的环境是什么样的。毫无疑问，我父亲爱我。但他是一个非常复杂的人物。我想出的最好的比喻是，他就像罗伯特·路易斯·史蒂文森小说中的“杰基尔与海德”，他可能前一分钟非常慈爱和关心，下一分钟突然变得非常愤怒和难以相处。对于一个年幼的孩子来说，不知道你的照顾者会表现出哪一面，这真的非常令人不安。这就是故事的核心。但如果你回溯20年，我根本不知道这一切。我当时是个年轻人。我已经有一些心理健康问题了。比如我从记事起就患有蜘蛛恐惧症，
remember, which was very bad. Even talking about them was difficult, let alone seeing one, which was way more traumatic. And then there were the early signs of OCD, which turned up when I was a teenager. Then, and it's interesting how these events kind of layer onto each other. The next thing that happened was that I unfortunately contracted pneumonia when I was 15. And I had to have very strong antibiotics to deal with the pneumonia, which absolutely categorically saved my life. Unfortunately, what they also did was basically strip my digestive system of all the good bacteria. And again, I know that now, I didn't know at the time what was going on. All I knew was that I got discharged from hospital with pneumonia a few days. I think it was Christmas Eve, actually. And then a couple of days later, I was in agony.
而且非常严重。谈论它们都很困难，更不用说看到一只了，那更具创伤性。然后是强迫症的早期迹象，出现在我十几岁的时候。然后，有趣的是这些事件是如何一层层叠加的。接下来发生的事情是，我在15岁时不幸患上了肺炎。我不得不服用非常强效的抗生素来治疗肺炎，这绝对救了我的命。不幸的是，它们也基本上剥夺了我消化系统中的所有益生菌。同样，我现在知道了，当时我并不知道发生了什么。我只知道我因肺炎出院几天后，我想实际上是平安夜，几天后我就痛苦不堪。
I couldn't eat anything. I literally could not eat anything. And nobody knew what was wrong with me. And to cut a long story short, I was in hospital for a number of weeks and it was an incredibly distressing experience and in particular distressing because unfortunately, it was a very busy time and I don't remember anyone really being kind to me. So I was on my own a lot of the time in a lot of pain. And secondly, nobody knew what was wrong with me. And I got some kind of misdiagnosis stuff coming in, which was really difficult to deal with as well. So basically, in a nutshell, I developed post-traumatic stress disorder from that and it really intensified my OCD. So that was after that I was being incredibly protective about germs. I mean, it's kind of natural in a way. I never want that to happen to me again. So I am just going to be very careful. But of course, it steps over into being a disorder when it kind of stops you functioning very well. So
我什么都吃不下。我真的什么都吃不下。没人知道我怎么了。长话短说，我在医院住了几周，那是一段极其痛苦的经历，特别痛苦的是，不幸的是，那是一段非常忙碌的时间，我不记得有人对我真正友善过。所以我大部分时间都独自一人，承受着巨大的痛苦。其次，没人知道我怎么了。我得到了一些误诊，这也很难处理。所以简而言之，我因此患上了创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），这加剧了我的强迫症。在那之后，我对细菌变得极其防备。我的意思是，这在某种程度上是自然的。我再也不想让那种事发生在我身上了。所以我只是要非常小心。但当然，当它阻止你正常生活时，它就变成了一种障碍。所以
I remember when I started my first jobs in London, it was things like touching door handles or buttons in the lift. And my particular favourite was having to shake people's hands. And I would actually try to actively avoid this by just holding bundles of stuff in my arms when I met people and just go, Oh, I'm sorry, I can't, I can't shake your hand, because I didn't want them to feel bad, because I knew it wasn't anything to do with them. It was my thing. But nonetheless, I didn't want to shake their hands. And I also carried antibacterial gel around with me everywhere. So that if I was forced into doing any of these things, I would just surreptitiously clean my hands afterwards to feel a bit better. And then the final bit of the story is that in my late 20s, and this is probably the most disturbing development,
我记得当我开始在伦敦的第一份工作时，比如触摸门把手或电梯按钮。我特别讨厌的是不得不与人握手。我实际上会通过在见到人时手里拿着一堆东西来积极避免这种情况，然后说：“哦，对不起，我不能，我不能和你握手。”因为我不想让他们感到难过，因为我知道这与他们无关。这是我自己的问题。但尽管如此，我不想和他们握手。我还随身携带抗菌凝胶。如果我被迫做这些事情，我会在事后偷偷清洁双手，以感觉好一点。故事的最后一部分是，在我20多岁时，这是最令人不安的发展，
I got full blown what I call responsibility OCD. So it was basically an action or inaction of mine harming someone else. And I mean, literally, I could hardly get to work. I had to walk to work and I could hardly get to work because I would see broken glass and think, oh, I better move that. Otherwise someone might fall over and or there's a banana skin. There's the classic banana skin or catching a stick or something in the corner of my eye and thinking, oh, is it a needle? Do I need to work? You know, all these things. It becomes all pervasive. And I know you'll know this. I get very frustrated when people say, oh, I'm just a little bit OCD. And I know they don't mean it
我患上了我称之为“责任强迫症”的全面症状。基本上就是我的行为或不作为会伤害到别人。我的意思是，我几乎无法去上班。我必须步行去上班，但我几乎无法到达，因为我会看到碎玻璃，心想：“哦，我最好把它移开，否则别人可能会摔倒。”或者有香蕉皮，经典的香蕉皮，或者在眼角看到一根棍子之类的东西，心想：“哦，那是针吗？我需要处理吗？”你知道，所有这些事情。它变得无处不在。我知道你肯定知道这一点。当人们说“哦，我有点强迫症”时，我会感到非常沮丧。我知道他们不是故意的，
badly, but I'm like, OCD is not a little bit. OCD is like a rogue program in a computer that just takes over and stops the proper programs from running. So that, I suppose, is an overview of some of the issues that I faced. And yeah, so there we go. There's a starter for 10. Thank you. And, you know, I'm just really sorry that you kind of had to experience all of that. And it obviously led to you probably during treatment for your OCD and your PTSD from the hospital stay led you to kind of explore and realize other things. And I just want to touch on the point that you'd said about, you know, I've no doubt that my dad loved me, but I think this is something that crops up quite often with my
但我会想，强迫症不是“一点点”。强迫症就像电脑里的流氓程序，它接管了一切，阻止了正常的程序运行。所以，我想这就是我所面临的一些问题的概述。好了，这就是开场白。谢谢。而且，你知道，我真的很抱歉你不得不经历这一切。这显然导致你在治疗强迫症和医院经历带来的创伤后应激障碍时，探索并意识到了其他事情。我想谈谈你提到的关于“我毫无疑问我父亲爱我”的观点，但我认为这在我的客户以及我的听众所接触的人群中经常出现，
clients and those that my listeners will be working with as well it's like he loved you the best he could but that doesn't mean that you didn't deserve more you know as a little baby as a child as even as an adult you know you deserved something more compassionate more consistent more that helped you thrive yeah so you know you know, I don't want to discredit the love that you did feel from him, but actually, he did the best he could, but that wasn't good enough. No, and I'll tell you something, Marianne. So I'm an active Christian. I'm on a real journey about what forgiveness means in this particular instance, because it's really, really tough. I don't know whether I can
就像他尽他所能地爱你，但这并不意味着你不值得拥有更多。你知道，作为一个婴儿，作为一个孩子，甚至作为一个成年人，你值得拥有更富有同情心、更一致、更能帮助你茁壮成长的东西。是的，所以我不想否定你从他那里感受到的爱，但实际上，他尽力了，但这还不够好。不，我告诉你一件事，玛丽安。我是一名虔诚的基督徒。我正在经历一段关于在这种特定情况下“宽恕”意味着什么的旅程，因为这真的非常非常艰难。我不知道我是否能
say he did the best he could in the circumstances he was in, which is a phrase that, you know, I just don't, I can't even tell you that. There were times latterly where he showed me, he actually admitted he was doing things intentionally when his guard was down. He actually died an alcoholic. So, but towards the end, he was, he always had an issue with alcohol but it became much worse and more pronounced towards the end and I remember once he was picking on me about something and I said surely you wouldn't make my life difficult in this way please please don't he was threatening to do something that would make make my life very tricky and he just looked at me and said what if I could get one over on you and I'll never forget I just thought my goodness you've
说他在那种情况下尽力了，这是一个我甚至无法说出口的短语。后来有几次他向我承认，当他放下防备时，他是故意做那些事情的。他最终死于酗酒。所以，但在最后，他一直有酒精问题，但在最后变得更严重、更明显。我记得有一次他因为某事挑剔我，我说：“你肯定不会这样让我的生活变得困难，请，请不要。”他威胁要做一些让我的生活非常棘手的事情，他只是看着我说：“如果我能胜过你呢？”我永远不会忘记，我当时想：“天哪，你刚才真的很诚实地承认这是预谋好的。”所以，是的，处理人们伤害你的情况确实非常非常棘手，试图弄清楚有多少是无意的，有多少是有意的，这很复杂。你有没有感觉到他的成长经历是什么样的？这完全是离经叛道、完全是他个人的问题，还是他在延续代际创伤？
just been really honest about actually being a bit premeditated about this so yeah look it is very very tricky to deal with situations where people have caused you harm and kind of trying to figure out how much was unintentional and how much was intentional is is tricky. Did you ever get a sense of what his upbringing was like and whether this was totally errant and totally rogue and all about him or whether he was kind of carrying on intergenerational trauma? It's a really good question and actually one of the things when I finally became aware of what the issue was, consciously aware, I put it aside for so long. I remember my counsellor would kind of ask me about my parents because I think she had figured out very early on what the issue was in general terms I would just say oh no don't look over there why are you asking me about that stop stop asking
这是一个非常好的问题。实际上，当我最终意识到问题所在时，我把它搁置了很久。我记得我的咨询师会问我关于我父母的事，因为我想她很早就从一般意义上弄清楚了问题所在。我只会说：“哦，不，别看那边，你为什么要问我那个？停，别再问我那个了。”然后最终我意识到了发生了什么，并开始反抗它。实际上，我现在正在挣扎的是——我母亲10年前去世了，然后我父亲去年去世了，遗憾的是在我们因为他的酗酒而疏远之后。而且，你父母在你母亲去世前一直在一起吗？是的，是的，他们在一起。但基本上没剩下什么人了。
me about that and then eventually I became aware of what was going on and began to kind of fight against it actually a little bit anyway what what I'm struggling with now so my mother died 10 years ago and then my father died last year sadly after we had estranged because of his alcoholism and there was and were your parents together until your mum died yes yes they were um and but there's basically no one left there There are very, very few people who know about my past. There are some people who remember me as a child with my parents. And I've actually gone back to some of them and asked them, can I chat to you honestly, just to get your impressions. And basically, all of them in their different ways have verified my story. Obviously, they didn't
很少有人知道我的过去。有些人记得我小时候和父母在一起的样子。我实际上回去找了他们中的一些人，问他们：“我可以诚实地和你聊聊吗？只是为了了解你们的印象。”基本上，他们每个人都以不同的方式证实了我的故事。显然，他们没有在家庭环境中看到我父亲关起门后的样子，但他们确实看到了他性格中困难的一面。所以我得到了那种验证，这很有帮助。但当谈到更久远的事情时，没有人可以交谈。我能说的是，我不认为他有一个困难的童年。我的意思是，我认为每个人都有不同的方面。从我读到的内容来看，我显然不是这方面的专家，但当谈到自恋时，他们谈论的背景之一是孩子被捧上神坛，这会导致那种自恋倾向的出现。我认为对他来说，他绝对是
see my father behind closed doors in a family situation, but they definitely saw that difficult streak in him. And they had. So I've got that validation, which is helpful. But when it comes to going further back, there is no one I can talk to. What I can say is that I do not think that he had a difficult childhood. I mean, I think everyone has aspects. From what I've read, and I'm obviously not an expert in this, but when you come to narcissism, one of the backgrounds they talk about is where a child is put on a pedestal, and that that can cause those kind of narcissistic things to come, tendencies to come out. And I think with him, he was definitely the favourite
他家三个孩子中最受宠的一个。这在很多方面都得到了证明。所以我的直觉是更多的是那样。这仍然是他必须处理的问题，因为我怀疑他被告知“世界是你的牡蛎，你真的很特别，你会去做惊人的事情”。事实上，他确实去做了非常惊人的事情，上了大学，我想是家里第一个，诸如此类的事情。我后来拼凑出他经历了很多失望，真正非常困难的失望。实际上，当我还是个蹒跚学步的孩子时，很多事情同时发生了。所以我只是拼凑起来，我的
of the three children in his family. And that was demonstrated in a number of ways. So my gut feeling is that it was more that. And that's still an issue that he had to deal with, because my suspicion is that he was kind of told the world is your oyster, you're really special, you're going to go and do amazing things. And in fact, he did go and do really, you know, amazing things, went to university, I think the first in the family and all that kind of thing. I then have pieced together that he had quite a lot of disappointments, really quite difficult disappointments that came his way. When I was a toddler, actually, a lot of things that happened all at once. So I just piecing it together, my
工作假设是，他觉得世界上一切都很棒，他可以做他想做的任何事。然后他突然受到了系统的冲击，这向他表明那不是真的。所有这些事情加在一起，可能导致了他一些更具问题性的行为。我不知道你是否认为这听起来可行。但是的。是的，这听起来确实可行。通常当我们与患有复杂性创伤诊断或复杂性创伤表现的人合作时，应该说，这就像是一组不同的症状，如果某人生命中有一个好或足够好的照顾者，这可能非常重要。你有过这样的人吗？那是你妈妈吗？还是她也比较复杂？这是一个非常有趣的问题。我再次强调，我母亲是一个美丽、美好的人，她想要孩子
my kind of working hypothesis, if you like, is that he felt that everything was brilliant in the world, and he could do what he wanted. And then he suddenly got shocks to the system, which showed him that wasn't true. And all of those things combined, were probably what led to some of his more problematic behaviour. I don't know if you think that sounds feasible. But yeah. Yeah, certainly sounds feasible. And often when we're working with people who have got a complex trauma diagnosis or complex trauma presentation, should we say, which is like a cluster of different can be really important that somebody's had some caregiver or someone in their life that's been a good or good enough figure have you had that and was that your mum or was she kind of complicated too so this is a really interesting question I again my mother was a beautiful wonderful person and she wanted children
胜过世界上的一切，这就是所有过去认识她的人告诉我的。她想要你胜过一切，我是唯一幸存的孩子，有很多流产和困难。在我年轻的时候，她绝对是一位了不起的母亲。我现在正在接受的部分，这更难，这并不是对她的反思，但她和我父亲的关系非常困难，她对他非常忠诚。就像她对他忠诚得令人难以置信，但这让她付出了代价，我现在能看出来了。
more than anything in the world and that's what everyone who knows her from the past tells me she wanted you more than anything and I was the only child who survived there were quite a lot of miscarriages and difficulties I she was definitely an amazing mother in my younger years. The bit which I am coming to terms with now, which is harder, and this is not a reflection on her, but she was in a very difficult relationship with my father and she was so loyal to him. Like she was unbelievably loyal to him, but it took its toll on her, which I can now see.
所以我现在意识到，好吧，我10年前失去了我的母亲。实际上，我可能在20年前就真正失去了她。因为当我回顾过去时，她变了。她变得有点像她以前自己的影子。这是我最近才更深刻理解的事情。所以是的，我认为她是让我比原本可能的情况更容易度过这一切的基础，这是肯定的。我认为这表现出来的方式之一是，你知道，你经常看到在童年经历过创伤的孩子，
So I've now realised, well, I physically lost my mother 10 years ago. Actually, I probably really lost her about 20 years ago. Because when I look back, she just changed. She became a bit of a shadow of her former self. And that is something I've only understood more recently. So yes, I think she was the foundation for making this easier for me than it might otherwise have been that's for sure and one of the ways I think that's played out is you know you often see children who've been through traumatic experiences in their childhood
他们后来可能会找一个同样困难、表现出类似问题行为的伴侣，然后你可能会陷入一种恶性循环。我质疑过很多次，为什么我嫁给了这么好的人？我确实嫁给了他，我的意思是，他是一个非常棒、充满爱心的丈夫，我们即将迎来结婚20周年纪念日。他嫁给我时并不知道他在家庭动态方面卷入了什么，并感到有点震惊。但我认为，也许这表明我确实了解什么是好的，我实际上是在寻找它，幸运的是我找到了，这是我康复的重要组成部分。是的，我很高兴你能嫁入一个可预测、一致、安全、冷静、始终尊重的家庭，
they might then go and get a partner who is also difficult and displays similar problematic behaviors and that you know you can get into a bit of a vicious cycle I've questioned quite a lot why did I marry such a wonderful person which I did I mean he is just a wonderful loving husband we're coming up to our 20th wedding anniversary um he married me not knowing what he was getting himself into in terms of the family dynamic and got a bit of a shock but I think I think maybe that was a sign that I did have an understanding of what good looked like and I was actually seeking it and found it luckily which was a huge part of my recovery. Yeah I'm really pleased that you've been able to marry into a family that's predictable, consistent, safe, calm, respectful all the time
希望如此，这真的带来了很大的不同。我不知道你后来是否自己成为了父母，但你知道，我认为这只是帮助你真正欣赏你所没有的东西。是的，不，你是绝对正确的。实际上，我和我丈夫选择不要孩子，这总是一个相当多方面的决定。但我会说，如果我真的很诚实，我只是知道我没有处于一个能成为好母亲的位置，那是其中的一部分。我本能地想：“我一团糟，如果我现在连自己都照顾不好，我怎么能照顾孩子呢？”我并不是说这对每个人都一样，我认为每个人出于各种原因做出自己的决定。我想我只是
hopefully and that really makes such a difference I don't know if you went on to become a parent yourself but you know I think it just helps you really appreciate what it was that you didn't have yeah no you're absolutely right actually my husband and I chose not to have children and that's always quite a multifaceted decision but I will say if I'm being really honest I just knew I was not in a place to be a good mother and that that was part of it I could instinctively I just thought I'm all over the place how on earth if I can't look after myself now I'm not saying that would be the case for everyone I think everyone makes their own decisions for a bunch of reasons. I think I just
感觉到了。我也并不真的想要孩子。我能够诚实地面对这一点，并想：“好吧，如果这不是我真正想要的，而且我认为这会是一场挣扎，那么也许这不是一件好事。”而我认为对于其他人，我可以看到，他们想：“好吧，这可能具有挑战性，但这是我真正想要的。”因此，这将帮助我，使我能够站出来做新事情，学习新事物和新的生活方式。所以是的，我认为核心可能是我并不真的想要孩子，因此决定这对我来说不值得，如果这说得通的话。说得通。而且我认为，你知道，对于孩子，我认为你需要非常非常想要，因为，你知道，他们会毁了你的生活。
felt it. I also just didn't really want it. And I was able to be honest about that and go, well, if it's not really something I am wanting, and I think it's going to be a struggle, then maybe that's not a good thing to do. Whereas I think with other people, I can see, they think, well, this may be challenging, but it's something I really want. And therefore, it'll help me, that'll enable me to step up and do, you know, do new things and learn new things and new ways of being. So yeah, I think at the heart of it was probably I didn't really want it, and therefore decided it wasn't, it wasn't worth it for me, if that makes sense. It does. And I think, you know, with children, I think you need to really, really want it because, you know, they'll wreck your life.
我有两个这样的“野兽”，你知道，我是在生命中稍晚的时候生下他们的，在现代标准下可能不算太晚，但我31岁时生了第一个。到那时，我已经拥有了如此美妙的生活。你知道，我一直在旅行。我是一名专业合格的心理学家。你知道，我结婚了。我经历过许多可爱的冒险，你知道，许多有趣、愚蠢的时光，许多严肃的时光，许多真正致力于自我提升的时间。我理智地选择烧毁这一切，成为一名父母，做一些不同的事情，你知道，我生命的下一代。但你必须真正非常想要这样做。你不能真的有点不确定，因为它是一个如此重大的选择。你是绝对正确的。完全正确。不幸的是，相比之下，我想说的是，我感觉我的20多岁和30多岁被偷走了。我知道这听起来有点消极，但感觉确实如此，我生命中身体状况最好的几年，我只是
I've got two of the beasts, you know, and I had them slightly later in life, probably not that late in terms of modern, but I had my first one when I was 31. And by that time I'd had such a wonderful life. You know, I'd been traveling. I was a professionally qualified psychologist. You know, I was married. I'd had many lovely adventures, you know, lots of funny, silly times, lots of serious times, lots of time to really work on myself. And I mindfully chose to burn all that to the ground and become a parent and do something different, you know, the next generation of my life. But you have to really, really want to do that. You can't really be a little bit unsure because it is such a big choice. You're absolutely right. Exactly. And unfortunately, by contrast, what I would say is I kind of feel like my 20s and my 30s were kind of stolen from me. I know that sounds a bit negative, but it really is how it felt that some of the physically best years of my life, I was just
如此不快乐。并不是说我没有过美好的时光，但我肯定不觉得我能承担任何其他事情。我勉强能维持我的职业生涯。我有一个成功的职业生涯，但因为背景中发生的一切，我觉得它很不稳定。是的，听起来你当时已经处于极限了。我只是想谈谈你关于你母亲所说的话。我认为你描述得很好，有时对于严重的抑郁症，它可能发生是因为某人觉得他们无法控制，或者他们没有能力控制。所以另一种变量，就像他们无法控制或没有能力控制，所以他们能做的另一种变量就是退缩，停止关心，并让
so unhappy. And it's not that I didn't have nice times, but I certainly didn't feel like I could take on anything else. I could just about keep my career going. And I had a successful career, but it felt precarious to me because of everything that was going on in the background. Yeah, it sounds like you're already at capacity. And I just wanted to touch on what you'd said about your mum, really. And I think what you nicely described there is that sometimes for a really deep depression, it can occur because someone feels like they can't take control, or they're not able to take control. And so the other kind of variable like they can't take control or they're not able to take control and so the other kind of variable that they can do is to just kind of withdraw and stop caring and kind of
一切在他们周围发生。而且，你知道，我不能给你的母亲下病理诊断，我也不想这样做。从你所说的来看，听起来就是发生了这种情况。所以你，她从你身边退缩了，她退缩到自己内心，只是为了继续在那个家庭和那段关系中生活下去。是的，我认为这是对所发生事情的一个很好的描述。她确实有抑郁倾向，你知道，那是遗传的，来自她的父亲。他在战争中服役，他回来后，你知道，深受影响。所以毫无疑问，我小时候也感染了一堆恐惧和焦虑，只是因为那种情绪一直萦绕着。而且，你知道，有，有不幸的时刻，它们很少见，它们非常罕见，但有时她会转而责怪我，把事情搞砸了。
let everything happen around them um and you know I can't pathologize your mum nor would I want to from what you're saying it sounds like that's what happened so you kind of she retreated from you she retreated within herself in order to just carry on showing up in that in that home and in that relationship yeah I think that is a very good description of what happened and she did have depressive tendencies which you know were genetic they came from her father he served in the war he came back you know, were genetic, they came from her father, he served in the war, he came back, you know, very, very affected by that. And so there's no doubt I picked up a bunch of fear and anxiety as a young kid as well, just because that was kind of hanging around. And, you know, there were, there were just unfortunate times, and they were rare, they were very rare, but there were times where she would turn and blame me for things that were going wrong.
就像，哦，当时我不知道该怎么办。我只是觉得我被扇了一巴掌。但现在我回顾过去，我意识到这只是，这只是因为她被困在那种境地而发泄。但正如我所说，她非常忠诚。而且我认为这只是因为她被困在那种境地而发泄，但正如我所说，她非常忠诚。而且我认为这是一个不同的时代，我认为这也是其中的一部分，我已经开始接受这一点，只是我认为，你知道，现在社会对夫妻分居更加宽容，并且有更多的赋权去做这件事，也许有更多的支持去这样做。几十年前情况并非如此。
And it's like, oh, and at the time I didn't know what to do with them. I just felt like I'd been kind of slapped in the face. But now I look back and I realise it was it was just again, it was just a lashing out because she was trapped in a situation. But as I say, so loyal. And I think it was just a lashing out because she was trapped in a situation but as I say so loyal and I think it was a different age I think that is part of it as well which I have begun to come to terms with is just I think you know nowadays society is more accepting of couples splitting up and of there being a bit more empowerment to do that and perhaps a bit more support out there to do that not so much the case, you know, roll back a few
所以这是另一回事。因为有时我会想：“为什么，为什么她不离开他？为什么她不保护我？带我离开那里？她看不出这有多大的破坏性吗？”同样，我无法回答所有这些问题，这很难。但事实就是，我认为对我来说，你会知道强迫症，很多是关于确定性的。你想要对事情有确定性。我想，在我的情况下，我想确定我是安全的，其他人也是安全的。在接受我的过去时，我不得不意识到我无法拥有确定性。我必须与此达成和解，并获得我能得到的最好的理解，以帮助我前进，而不必沉迷于所有
decades. So that's something else. Because sometimes I thought to myself, why didn't why didn't she leave him? Why didn't she protect me? And get me out of it? Couldn't she see how damaging it was? And again, I can't have answers to all these questions, which is quite hard. But it is just, I think for me, you'll know with OCD, a lot of it is about certainty. You want to have certainty about things. I want to, you know, in my case, I want to be sure that I'm safe and that everyone else is safe. With coming to terms with my past, I've had to realise I cannot have certainty. And I have to come to peace with that and get the best possible understanding I can to help me move forward without getting obsessed about all the
我无法知道的细节。是的，绝对。考虑到什么是复杂性创伤后应激障碍，我发现对于我合作的许多客户，他们甚至不一定意识到他们有一个创伤性的童年。因为实际上，当我们观察它的标志时，对于那些看起来作为独立事件可能相当无关紧要的事情，分数加起来很快。有些是无关紧要的，有些显然不是。但人们可能会对我说：“我一直觉得有点焦虑、不安全、抑郁。我想这只是我，你知道，这只是我的错。我不知道为什么我一直这样。”实际上，当我们观察他们的经历时，你知道，如果我们观察一种粗略的衡量标准，比如不良童年经历量表（ACE量表），它观察10个关键问题，他们可能
details that I can't know about. Yeah, absolutely. And thinking about what is kind of complex post-traumatic stress disorder, what I find is that with many of the clients I work with, they don't even necessarily realize they've had a traumatic childhood. Because actually, when we look at kind of the markers for it, the points add up quite quickly for things that might look like quite inconsequential things as standalone. Some of them are inconseququential some of them are not obviously um but people might say to me I've always just felt a bit anxious unsafe depressed I think it's just me like you know it's just my fault like I don't know why I've always been this way and actually when we come to look at their experiences you know if we're looking at a kind of a rough and ready measure like the adverse childhood experiences scale the ACE scale it's looking at 10 key questions they might be
在量表上得六或七分，而CPTSD的指标阈值是四分。当你能够向他们解释这一点时，这就像白天和黑夜一样，你知道，那不是正确的术语，对吧？术语是什么？白天和黑夜？白天和黑夜。白天和黑夜。我们会保留这一点，只是为了展示我们是人类。你知道，这可以对他们产生变革性的影响。仅仅是那种认识，即“哦，我感觉如此是有原因的”。而且实际上，这对于我的感受，以及帮助他们感到
scoring six or seven on the scale with the threshold for indicative CPTSD being four and when you're able to just explain that to them it it can be like light and day, you know, in terms of that's not the right term, is it? What's the term? Night and day? Night and day. Night and day. We'll leave that in just to show that we're human. You know, it's it can be transformational for them. Just that one recognition that actually, oh, there's a reason why I feel like I do. And actually, this makes a lot of sense for the way that I feel, and for then helping them feel
对他们年轻时的自己有更多的同情心，他们可能一直带着那个自己，讨厌，实际上，厌恶他们的经历，并责怪他们自己的经历。这对你来说怎么样？又是一个大师级的解释，玛丽安。我的意思是，对我来说，我只是处于坚定的否认中。所以如果有人，包括我的咨询师——我因为强迫症去找我的咨询师，因为有了责任强迫症，我真的以为我疯了。除此之外，我已经有了卫生强迫症、蜘蛛恐惧症，我甚至还没提到我患有慢性失眠，而且我整个成年生活都这样。这可能是持续时间最长的，现在仍然伴随着我。看看它如何演变会很有趣，但我只是以为我疯了，
more compassion for their younger self, who they might well have been kind of dragging around with them hating, actually, and loathing what their experiences were like and blaming them for their experiences like how's that been for you again a masterful explanation there Marianne I mean I think for me I was just in rock solid denial so if someone including my count so I went to my counsellor for my OCD because I with the responsibility OCD I literally thought I was losing my mind and on top of that I already had the hygiene OCD spider phobia I haven't even mentioned to you the fact that I have chronic insomnia and have done all my adult life still that's probably the longest lasting that's still with me now and it'd be interesting to see how that evolves but I just thought I was going mad
我以为是我的错。我只是以为我是一个疯子。我不知道还能说什么。她显然知道她不能把我逼得太紧。非常有趣的事实是，我结婚后的第一个圣诞节，我丈夫，我丈夫看着我父亲对我发火，并因为某事责怪我，那是一场可怕的争吵。他总是喜欢在圣诞节前发火。然后我们都必须恢复，因为我母亲热爱圣诞节。所以我们都必须让它奏效。这太可怕了。显然，我甚至不记得这一点，在我父亲走后，我丈夫只是坐在那里惊呆了，心想：“那是什么？”我对他说：“我知道这是错的。我知道这不健康，但我必须为了我母亲留下来。我不能离开她。”现在，在那之后，
and I thought it was my fault I just thought I'm a crazy person. I don't know what else to say. And she obviously knew that she couldn't push me too far. The very interesting fact was, my very first married Christmas, my husband, my husband watched my father blow up at me and blame me for something in a horrible argument. He always used to blow up just before Christmas. And then we all had to recover because my mother loved Christmas. And so we all had to make it work. And it was hideous. And apparently, and I don't even remember this, after my father had gone away and my husband was just sitting there stunned, thinking, what was that? I said to him, I know this is wrong. I know it's not healthy, but I have to stick around for my mother. I cannot leave her. Now, after that,
显然，我多年来什么都没说。事实上，我丈夫后来也去看了我的咨询师。她实际上是我们教会的牧师。他显然在某个时候和她谈过，想把我从那种境地中带走，因为他能看出这有多大的破坏性。每次我回去，就像我又退了一步，即使我在此期间可能已经迈出了一些试探性的步伐。她只是显然对他说：“如果你试图太早把她拉出来，如果你强迫她在她还没准备好时做出选择，她可能会做出你意想不到的选择。那可能只是完全，你知道，不是她长期真正想要的，但她可能会选择她的父母。”所以我当时完全处于否认状态，这是一个非常温和的过程。但我想最终，我会说，他开始做越来越多离谱的事情，其中一些是由我母亲的疾病引起的。她得了癌症，而且，你知道，正如这些事情一样，一点也不愉快。我们觉得这很困难是可以理解的，但他实际上在平安夜午夜前把我赶出了家门，那年她做了手术。我的意思是，我真的，我走在苏格兰荒郊野外的一条黑路上，无处可去。我丈夫当时和他家人在一起。
apparently, I didn't say anything for years. And in fact, my husband then went to see my counsellor as well. She was actually our minister at our church. And he apparently talked to her at one point about wanting to just take me out of the situation because he could see how damaging it was. Every time I went back, it's like I was taking another step back, even if I may have taken some tentative steps forward in the meantime. And she just apparently said to him, if you try to pull her out too soon, if you force her into making a choice when she's not ready, she may make the choice you're not expecting. And that may just be completely, you know, not's not ready she may make the choice you're not expecting and that
显然，我好几年什么都没说。事实上，我丈夫后来也去看了我的心理咨询师，她其实也是我们教会的牧师。显然，他曾一度跟她谈过，说想把我从那种处境中带走，因为他看得出那对我伤害有多大。每次我回去，就像是又退了一步，即便我在此期间可能已经试探性地向前迈了几步。显然她当时就对他说，如果你太早试图把她拉出来，如果你强迫她在还没准备好的时候做出选择，她可能会做出你意想不到的选择。那可能完全，你知道，还没准备好，她可能会做出你意想不到的选择，而那
may just be completely you know not what actually what she wants in the long term either but she might pick her parents so I was just in total denial and it was a very gentle process but I think in the end I would say I he began to just do more and more outrageous things and some of it was brought on by my mother's illness. She had cancer and it was, it was, you know, as these things are not pleasant at all. And it's understandable that we would find that difficult, but he actually drove me out of the house just before midnight on Christmas Eve, the year she had had her operation. I mean, I literally, I was walking down a dark road in the middle of nowhere in Scotland with nowhere to go. My husband was with his with his family.
可能完全，你知道，也不是她长远来看真正想要的，但她可能会选择她的父母。所以我当时完全处于否认状态，这是一个非常温和的过程，但我认为最终我会说，他开始做出越来越多令人发指的事情，其中一些是由我母亲的病情引起的。她得了癌症，你知道，这些事情一点也不愉快。我们觉得这很困难是可以理解的，但他竟然在我母亲手术那年的平安夜午夜前夕把我赶出了家门。我的意思是，我当时真的走在苏格兰荒郊野外一条黑暗的路上，无处可去。而我丈夫当时正和他的家人在一起。
And I thought I wasn't going back. And then my father eventually picked me up in the car. We didn't say anything, just drove back. And I will never forget. We got to the driveway, he stopped the car. And he looked at me and he said, he said well Alexandra are you ready to give in yet and I just thought I can't believe you actually came to get me you saw that I was so badly affected that I actually walked out of the house and you're asking me if I'm ready to give in and I said no and that was a profound moment for me I was like I don't care if Christmas is messed up this year I am not giving in on this ridiculous argument that you have created out of nowhere. So we went into the house. I went to my room thinking, goodness knows where this is now headed. And eventually my mum came and knocked on the door and said, your father would like to see you. And I said, really? And went downstairs and suddenly I found myself sitting on his knee.
我以为我不会再回去了。后来我父亲最终开车来接我。我们什么也没说，只是开车回去。我永远不会忘记，我们到了车道，他停下车，看着我说：“亚历山德拉，你准备好屈服了吗？”我当时心想，真不敢相信你竟然来接我，你明明看到我受了这么大的打击，甚至都离家出走了，你竟然还问我是否准备好屈服了。我说没有。那对我来说是一个深刻的时刻，我心想，我不在乎今年的圣诞节是否被搞砸了，我绝不会在你凭空捏造的这种荒谬争论上屈服。于是我们进了屋。我回到房间，心想，天知道接下来会发生什么。最终我妈妈来敲门说，你父亲想见你。我说，真的吗？我下楼后，突然发现自己坐在他的膝盖上。
I'm way too old for that now, but I'm sitting on his knee and he's saying, Alexandra, you do know that I love you, don't you? And my mother, in one of her wonderful moments of clarity, just looked at him and said, I don't think she does know that right now, to be honest. And I tell that story just to say his behaviour got worse as I got older. I don't think he could cope with me being an independent human being who voiced my own opinions if they were not you know similar to his and when he became more extreme and as I was growing in confidence and had my husband and began to see other models I just began to say no and over time that got to a point where I could say that I was my own human being and could see that that behavior was not accurate not not good not not healthy and
我现在已经太大了，不适合那样做了，但我坐在他膝盖上，他说：“亚历山德拉，你知道我爱你，对吧？”我母亲在她难得的清醒时刻之一，看着他说：“老实说，我不认为她现在知道这一点。”我讲这个故事只是想说，随着我年龄的增长，他的行为变得更糟了。我不认为他能接受我成为一个独立的个体，如果我的观点与他不一致，我就表达自己的意见。当他变得更加极端，而我越来越自信，有了丈夫并开始看到其他榜样时，我开始说不。随着时间的推移，我终于能够说我是一个独立的个体，并能看出那种行为是不准确、不好且不健康的，
not really what a father should be doing with his child so yeah and you know when we're parents or even I don't know I care about everybody I like I want everyone to be safe I don't want you to be vulnerable walking alone in the dark at midnight on Christmas Eve like I don't want that for anybody, let alone my own children, you know, to think that that's happening or happened and people are knowingly doing that. It's just, you know, it's just horrendous, isn't it? Yeah, it's tough to look back on. And it's been really interesting, actually, as I have decided to talk about my story and to share it to to raise awareness because I still do not believe that emotional abuse is as well understood as other forms of abuse I mean
那并不是一个父亲应该对孩子做的事。所以，是的，你知道当我们为人父母时，或者甚至我不知道，我关心每一个人，我希望每个人都安全。我不希望你在平安夜午夜独自走在黑暗中感到脆弱，我不希望任何人经历这些，更不用说我自己的孩子了。你知道，想到这种事正在发生或曾经发生，而人们明知故犯，这真是太可怕了，不是吗？是的，回首往事很艰难。事实上，当我决定讲述我的故事并分享它以提高人们的认识时，这非常有趣，因为我仍然不认为人们对情感虐待的理解像其他形式的虐待那样深刻，我的意思是
you're absolutely correct the ACE study shows how you know how difficult these different experiences are for children and yet I still think there's a difference in perception in people's minds and sometimes they just think oh well just toughen up it's uh it's just words what are you worrying about and it's like so much more complicated than that so I've started to to tell share my story and I'll be honest with you there are the really supportive people there are then the people who just don't say anything to me and they're just not comfortable to say anything and then I've had a few people actually criticize it which has been fascinating but I am at least in a strong enough place now I can say well fine you can hold that and they're just not comfortable to say anything. And then I've had a few people actually criticise it, which has been fascinating, but I am at least in a strong enough place now that I can say, well, fine,
你是完全正确的。ACE研究表明这些不同的经历对儿童来说是多么困难，但我仍然认为人们心中的认知存在差异。有时他们只是认为，哦，坚强点，这只是言语而已，你在担心什么？但这比那复杂得多。所以我开始分享我的故事，老实说，有非常支持我的人，也有什么都不对我说的人，他们只是不舒服，什么都不说。还有几个人实际上批评了它，这很有趣，但我现在至少处于一个足够强大的位置，我可以对自己说，好吧，没关系，你可以持有那种观点，
you can hold that view if you want to, but I am doing this not to shame my father. I, you know, I'm not doing it for that reason. I'm doing it because there's no other family member to be distressed by what I'm saying. That there's, you know, there are no siblings, there are no other close family members. So I am actually at liberty to tell this story honestly and I think you know I already have proof that people are
如果你想持有那种观点，那是你的事，但我这样做并不是为了羞辱我的父亲。我不是为了那个原因才这么做的。我这样做是因为没有其他家庭成员会因为我的话而感到困扰。没有兄弟姐妹，也没有其他亲近的家庭成员。所以我实际上有自由诚实地讲述这个故事，而且我认为你知道，我已经有证据表明人们
coming to me and saying this is really valuable um so that that's that's kind of the essence of why I'm doing it yeah and more and more podcasts and kind of you know media appearances that you get you know it gives people more and more opportunity to really see what this has been like and what this is like. I understand your dad was reasonably high profile as well. Yeah, he was a member of parliament for nearly 20 years. So and I think it's really interesting because I think he was kind of drawn to that kind of career because, you know, there's a bit of there's a lot of antagonism there.
来找我说这非常有价值。所以这就是我做这件事的本质。是的，越来越多的播客和媒体露面，让人们有更多机会真正看到这曾经是什么样子，以及现在是什么样子。我明白你父亲的知名度也相当高。是的，他做了近20年的国会议员。我认为这很有趣，因为我觉得他被那种职业所吸引，因为那里有很多对抗。
It's just, I'm not saying by the way that all MPs are like that. I've actually met quite a lot of members of parliament because as I was growing up, it was the environment I was in. And there are some really amazing people who want to serve us and, you know, help lead the country. But I do think that element of antagonism is just an interesting one um and I I think he thrived on it to be honest uh to some extent and um yeah I'm not sure he wasn't ever minister for children no no he did not become a minister uh but all right so you know I think it's been a really illuminating conversation. I feel like it probably could have been two or three podcast episodes to really, you know, do this topic justice. But tell us a little bit about your book.
我并不是说所有的议员都是那样的。我实际上见过很多国会议员，因为在我成长过程中，那就是我所处的环境。有一些非常了不起的人，他们想要服务我们，帮助领导这个国家。但我确实认为那种对抗的因素很有趣，老实说，在某种程度上他很享受这种对抗。我不确定他是否曾担任过儿童部长，不，他没有成为部长。但好吧，我认为这是一次非常有启发性的谈话。我觉得这可能需要两到三集播客才能真正公正地探讨这个话题。但请给我们介绍一下你的书。
Oh, thank you. So, well, I've obviously told you a little bit about Christmas being difficult for me. And I think that is a story you hear replicated quite a lot because families are thrown together. And Christmas, therefore, becomes a bit of a flash point if there are family difficulties. My mother loved Christmas. I loved it, all the beautiful stuff. But I got to the point where because all of these difficult things had happened year after year after year, I just retreated from it altogether and this was round about the time I estranged from my father as well where the relationship with him was kind of getting to the point where it was falling over and there was the year I just didn't did nothing we had no tree we had no presents we didn't visit family it was just my husband me husband and me
哦，谢谢。我已经告诉过你圣诞节对我来说很困难。我认为这是一个你经常听到的故事，因为家庭成员被强行聚在一起。如果家庭内部有困难，圣诞节就会成为一个爆发点。我母亲热爱圣诞节。我也喜欢，喜欢所有美好的事物。但我到了一个地步，因为这些困难的事情年复一年地发生，我完全退缩了。那大约也是我与父亲疏远的时候，我们之间的关系到了崩溃的边缘。那一年我什么都没做，没有圣诞树，没有礼物，没有拜访亲戚，只有我和我丈夫
in our house not doing Christmas and in fact Christmas Day, we just went out for a walk on a rather wet Scottish day to a rather wet Scottish waterfall, just to do something. So the next year, I had estranged from my father by that point. And I remember just thinking, do I want to have lost this thing forever because of what happened to me in the past? Well, no, I don't. I want to reclaim it, hence the title of the book Reclaiming Christmas and I did an active experiment over about six weeks and I did all sorts of uh all sorts of different well-being techniques and healing techniques focusing on different aspects so for example um around the mind I was thinking about affirmations now positive affirmations can be done really badly and I um with my scientific background I have quite a I care a lot about evidence and how these things are used so for me for example just saying I am not fearful I can do and I'm brave enough to do
在家里，没有过圣诞节。事实上，圣诞节那天，我们只是去苏格兰一个相当潮湿的地方散步，去了一个相当潮湿的苏格兰瀑布，只是为了做点什么。所以第二年，那时我已经与父亲疏远了。我记得我当时想，我是否想因为过去发生在我身上的事而永远失去这个节日？不，我不想。我想找回它，这就是书名《找回圣诞节》的由来。我进行了大约六周的积极实验，尝试了各种各样的幸福感技巧和治愈技巧，专注于不同的方面。例如，关于思维，我考虑了肯定语。现在，积极的肯定语如果做得不好会适得其反，而我有着科学背景，我非常看重证据以及这些东西是如何被使用的。所以对我来说，例如，仅仅说“我不害怕，我可以做，我足够勇敢去做
anything I want was just not true because fear has been such a core aspect of my life so it's more about saying I am becoming less fearful I am learning to become you know words like that so the mind the emotions the body and the spirit just finding different ways to yeah I was just going to interject because you've really nicely given us an in to OCD as well so with OCD you might have like a magic thought or phrase or kind of action that calms whatever it is that, you know, that makes it okay. And that, that almost that, that, that affirmation almost could have been that like, I'm safe, I'm okay, like, but actually, that loses its potency over time, doesn't it? And then you kind of need to ramp it up.
任何我想做的事”是不真实的，因为恐惧一直是我生命中的核心部分。所以更重要的是说“我正在变得不那么害怕，我正在学习变得……”诸如此类的词。思维、情绪、身体和精神，只是寻找不同的方式来……我刚才想插话，因为你很好地为我们引入了强迫症（OCD）的话题。对于强迫症，你可能会有某种神奇的想法、短语或动作来平复让你感到不安的事情，让一切变得没关系。那种肯定语几乎可能变成那样，比如“我很安全，我很好”，但实际上，随着时间的推移，它会失去效力，不是吗？然后你需要加强它。
Yeah. And I think, as I say, for me, with with me with affirmations it's a bit like um have a statement that is stretching you but not stretching you so that you break or a bit like a muscle you might pull your muscle if you try to stretch too far and so I the way I try and do it with myself and with clients is just you know you're stretching yourself more and more over time and that gets you to a stronger position so um, and yeah, I just, I did, to give you the inside scoop, I did reclaim my Christmas. I now do love it again, but it did require being quite intentional and things like when bad memories came back to me, what did I do with that? How did I deal with that? So it wasn't all just fun and games. There was an element of how do I hold space?
是的。正如我所说，对我来说，肯定语就像是一个能让你伸展但又不会让你断裂的陈述，或者有点像肌肉，如果你拉伸得太远可能会拉伤肌肉。所以我尝试对自己和客户使用的方法是，随着时间的推移，你逐渐拉伸自己，这会让你处于一个更强大的位置。所以，是的，为了给你内部消息，我确实找回了我的圣诞节。我现在又爱上它了，但这确实需要非常刻意。比如当糟糕的记忆浮现时，我该怎么处理？我如何应对？所以这不仅仅是娱乐和游戏。还有一个如何保持空间的问题。
I remember one day in my journal, and journaling has become very important to me, I just did a huge, great scribble on the page in the run-up to Christmas. It wasn't even words. It was just a massive scribble. And I'm really quite, I like my journal and I treat it quite well and I felt really bad,
我记得有一天在我的日记里——写日记对我来说变得非常重要——在圣诞节前夕，我在页面上乱涂乱画了一大片。那甚至不是文字，只是巨大的涂鸦。我真的很喜欢我的日记，我对待它很好，我当时感觉很糟糕，
but I just had to get it out. There were different ways, obviously, of expressing our emotions safely, but I just had to get it out. There are different ways, obviously, of expressing our emotions safely, but also being honest with ourselves as well. Absolutely. Where can people get the book if they would like to? I'll obviously pop a link in the show notes, but if they want to head straight there,
但我必须把它发泄出来。显然，有不同的方式可以安全地表达我们的情绪，但我们也要对自己诚实。绝对是这样。如果人们想要这本书，可以在哪里买到？我显然会在节目说明中放一个链接，但如果他们想直接去那里，
where can they get hold of a copy? So it's on Amazon. You can get paperback or Kindle, or I even recorded an audio book version upstairs in a little cupboard. So you've got all the options if you want it. Amazing. And I think just before we started, you were saying that you've got a little sibling for your book coming along as well. Could you tell us a little bit about that one? Yes, thank you so much. So my second book is
他们可以在哪里买到副本？它在亚马逊上。你可以买平装本或Kindle版，我甚至在楼上的一个小储藏室里录制了有声书版本。所以如果你想要的话，你有所有的选择。太棒了。我想在我们开始之前，你说过你的书还有一个“小兄弟”要出版了。你能给我们介绍一下那本书吗？是的，非常感谢。所以我的第二本书
in its early stages. It hasn't got a title yet, but effectively it's about sing after the storm. And the idea is how do you find your voice? How do you find your song and then sing it with gusto after you've been through a storm? And I think particularly for a lot of us, it's not just one storm, it's kind of multiple storms that one goes through and it can leave one a bit disorientated, a bit small, you know, all of those things. So my work and that book is going to be all about how do we make that journey, not just to get out of the storm in one piece, but then to grow positively afterwards. So yes, I'm working on that now. And if you're interested, you can head over to my website to have a little poke around and that's damselnotindistress.co.uk
还处于早期阶段。它还没有书名，但实际上它是关于“风暴后的歌唱”。核心思想是：你如何找到自己的声音？你如何找到自己的歌，并在经历风暴后充满激情地歌唱？我认为对我们很多人来说，这不仅仅是一场风暴，而是经历多场风暴，这会让人感到迷失方向、渺小，你知道，所有这些感觉。所以我的工作和那本书将全部关于我们如何完成那段旅程，不仅是完整地走出风暴，而且在之后积极地成长。所以是的，我现在正在写那本书。如果你感兴趣，可以去我的网站逛逛，网址是damselnotindistress.co.uk
okay lovely can we also follow you on socials somewhere as well Alexandra yes I am on you can find me on Facebook and Instagram I can give you the details and we can pop them underneath the variations on damsel not in distress basically okay perfect you're not you're not on LinkedInin though i love linkedin yes i actually am i don't think about it so much these days because i'm not so much in the in the corporate space but i'm still there so okay so you're alexandra walker on linkedin that's right perfect i'll make sure that i connect and we'll share all of your details if you ping those over to me we can make sure that they're all in the show notes and magically on screen as well for people that are watching on youtube thank you so much for your time and helping
好的，太棒了。我们可以在社交媒体上关注你吗，亚历山德拉？是的，你可以在Facebook和Instagram上找到我。我可以给你详细信息，我们可以把它们放在下面，基本上是“Damsel Not In Distress”的变体。好的，太完美了。你不在领英（LinkedIn）上吗？我喜欢领英。是的，我其实在上面，但我最近不太考虑它，因为我不太在企业领域活动，但我还在那里。好的，所以你在领英上是亚历山德拉·沃克（Alexandra Walker）。没错，太完美了。我会确保与你联系，如果你把这些详细信息发给我，我们可以确保它们都在节目说明中，并且对于在YouTube上观看的人来说，也会神奇地出现在屏幕上。非常感谢你抽出时间帮助
illuminate our audience about kind of about your experiences but also kind of the more wider concepts involved in emotional abuse in emotional abuse and complex trauma you're so welcome it's been a pleasure to be here thank you marianne. Oh, thank you so much to our guest for today, Alexandra. Please do go and connect with her. And if you'd like to know more about her story, please do consider checking out her book, Reclaiming Christmas. What has this evoked for you? I would love to know what you think to it. Come and let me know in the Aspiring Psychologist community on Facebook, which is also the home of Marianne's Mindset and Motivation sessions. I want to be on your team. I want to help you keep striving for whatever professional
启发我们的听众了解你的经历，以及情感虐待和复杂创伤中涉及的更广泛的概念。不客气，很高兴能来到这里，谢谢你，玛丽安。哦，非常感谢我们今天的嘉宾亚历山德拉。请务必去与她联系。如果你想了解更多关于她的故事，请考虑看看她的书《找回圣诞节》。这引起了你什么样的共鸣？我很想知道你的想法。来Facebook上的“Aspiring Psychologist”社区告诉我，那里也是玛丽安的“心态与动力”课程的所在地。我想成为你的团队成员。我想帮助你不断追求你想要实现的任何专业
qualification route it is that you want to achieve. Please, with that in mind, do come and connect and follow with me over on my social channels. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, everywhere that you could hope to imagine. And if you're watching this on YouTube, please do like, subscribe, share your favorite episodes with your friends. That would be so appreciated. And if you're listening to this as an MP3, please do take a moment to rate and review on Apple Podcasts and to give me a rating. And if you're listening to this as an MP3, please do take a moment to rate and review on Apple Podcasts and to give me a rating. And if you could consider following the show, that would be so, so appreciated. And if you'd like to know more about career routes to clinical psychology or career routes to professional psychology, please check out the Aspiring Psychologist
资格认证途径。考虑到这一点，请务必在我的社交频道上与我联系并关注我。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，在你能想象到的任何地方都能找到我。如果你是在YouTube上观看，请点赞、订阅，并与你的朋友分享你最喜欢的剧集。那将不胜感激。如果你是在听MP3版本，请花点时间在Apple Podcasts上评分和评论。如果你能考虑关注这个节目，那将非常非常感激。如果你想了解更多关于临床心理学的职业途径或专业心理学的职业途径，请查看《Aspiring Psychologist》
Collective book, the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. And if you're ready for the next step, the Aspiring Psychologist membership. And come and download your free 10-page psychology success guide, which you can do by going to my website, www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk, and then looking at the free resources tab at the top. You can be the first to know that there is going to be a change in my website. So there's going to be a new home for you, my wonderful, aspiring psychologists, and then a separate page for my media work and one-to-one so as soon as I have information about that you will be the first to know thank you so much for being part of my world wishing you well with whatever stage of your career you're at if you've got specific requests
集体书籍，《临床心理学家集体》书籍。如果你准备好迈出下一步，可以加入《Aspiring Psychologist》会员。并下载你的免费10页心理学成功指南，你可以通过访问我的网站www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk，然后查看顶部的免费资源标签来完成。你可以第一时间知道我的网站将会有所改变。所以，我的精彩的准心理学家们，你们将有一个新的家，然后会有单独的页面用于我的媒体工作和一对一咨询。所以一旦我有相关信息，你们将是第一批知道的人。非常感谢你们成为我世界的一部分，祝愿你们在职业生涯的任何阶段都一切顺利。如果你有具体的要求
for podcast episodes or content you'd like me to cover please don't be a stranger let me know thank you so much for being part of my world and i'll look forward to catching up with you for our next episode of the podcast which will be available for youtube from 10 a.m on saturdays and for the mp3 version 6 a.m on mondays take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories
关于播客剧集或你希望我涵盖的内容，请不要见外，告诉我。非常感谢你们成为我世界的一部分，我期待在下一集播客中与你们相见，该节目将于周六上午10点在YouTube上发布，MP3版本将于周一上午6点发布。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《Aspiring Psychologist》，我是玛丽安博士。我叫贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同故事的内容非常有趣，
and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及人们是如何成为临床心理学家的。这让我感到惊讶，原来有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有成为心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。